[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und marietas lomka
guten Abend für die Ampelkoalition war
heute sozusagen die standesamtliche
Trauung mit Betonung auf amtlich die
Unterzeichnung des Koalitionsvertrags
ist ein wichtiger aber letztlich doch
eher förmliche Akt das feierliche kommt
erst morgen mit Kanzlerwahl und
Vereidigung bei der Pressekonferenz der
drei Koalitionäre heute wurde aber auch
schon sichtbar dass sich zumindest die
drei führungsmänner auf dem neuen
Parkett im Moment noch so vorsichtig
bewegen als liefen sie über rohe Eier
auf Fragen nach möglichen Konflikten
sprach Christian Lindner davon sein
künftiges Haus sei ein
ermöglichungsministerium und Robert
Habeck sieht keine Schmerzgrenzen
sondern wachstumsfreuden man wird sehen
wie freudig die drei dann tatsächlich
zusammenwachsen aus Berlin Andreas
Künast
es muss am Ende dieses Tages ein paar
hundert Fotos geben von 13
Unterschriften auf drei
Koalitionsverträgen für alle die endlich
wissen wollen wie Olaf Scholz Olaf
Scholz geschrieben hat es ist Tag 72
nach der Bundestagswahl als ich das
Bündnis Scholz schriftlich verspricht
Deutschland so stark zu verändern wie
seit 100 Jahren nicht außer dem nächsten
Kanzler dem nächsten Vizekanzler und dem
nächsten vize-vizekanzler unterschreiben
alle Parteichefs alle Fraktionschefs
alle Generalsekretäre
vor der hauptstadtpässe dann das
Amtsverständnis der drei ampelmänner als
Kanzler des bevölkerungsreichsten und
wirtschaftsstärksten Mitgliedstaats
sieht sich Scholz nicht nur dem
Fortschritt Deutschlands verpflichtet
sondern auch dem der EU so unterschreibt
Olaf Scholz und so versteht er den Job
eines Kanzlers wir können nicht so
agieren wie es vielleicht der eine oder
die andere ab und zu mal tut im eigenen
Land heftig auftreten das ein bisschen
gegen Brüssel wettern dann dort ganz
gute Kompromisse machen und wieder
zurückkommen und sagen ist aber alles
gut geworden sondern wir müssen von
vornherein dafür sorgen dass das gut
werden ein Teil unserer nationalen
Politik ist im gemeinschaftlichen
Interesse Europas das wird so sein für
den Wirtschafts- und klimaminister steht
und fällt die Regierung mit dem Ziel das
Industrieland Deutschland bei laufendem
Betrieb auf klimaneutral umzustellen so
schreibt Robert Habeck und davor der
Respekt ich will also an der Stelle
sagen dass bei allem Sonntagsreden die
es immer gibt für mehr Klimaschutz und
irgendwie sind alle für erneuerbare
Energien das nicht ohne Zumutungen zu
haben sein wird wir werden viel
miteinander als Land als Gesellschaft zu
diskutieren haben wenn wir diese Ziele
umsetzen wollen als einziges
Regierungsmitglied hat der
Finanzminister ein Vetorecht der Name
Christian Lindner soll aber nicht für
den großen Verhinderer stehen wenn
dieses Programm das diese Koalition sich
vorgenommen hat realisiert worden sein
wird dann werden wir in Deutschland ein
mobiles aber auch wesentlich
klimafreundlicheres Land sein und das zu
ermöglichen das ist unsere gemeinsame
Aufgabe und der leisten auch wir die FDP
unsere Beiträge zum Nachfolger Lindners
als
fDP-Fraktionschef wird am Nachmittag der
Finanzexperte Christian dürr gewählt die
grünen Fraktion kürt Britta Hasselmann
und Katharina dröge morgen Mittag werden
die ampelminister ihre amtseide ablegen
und morgen Nachmittag ist die Zeit der
Überschriften vorbei
Olaf Scholz sprach heute früh auch vom
Morgen des Aufbruchs der wird womöglich
noch etwas warten müssen weil im heute
gerade so viel Krise ist Scholz so viel
steht fest wird von Anfang an ein
krisenkanzler sein 100 Tage Schonfrist
und ähnliches kann diese Regierung wohl
vergessen die wird es nicht geben
angesichts einer grassierenden Pandemie
symptomatisch dafür ist dass die
ampellianer schon vor Amtsantritt ihre
ersten Parlamentsbeschlüsse nachbessern
müssen die Zeit der Tat die laut
Christian Lindner nun beginne ist wohl
auch eine Zeit der Erkenntnis dass man
manches im Nachhinein betrachtet lieber
nicht gesagt oder getan hätte weiß auch
der bisherige Gesundheitsminister Spahn
mit ihm habe ich darüber vor der Sendung
gesprochen doch zunächst der Bericht von
Ines Trams
das ist neu im Bundestag ab heute müssen
die Abgeordneten auch am Platz Maske
tragen über Mund und Nase einige von der
afd-protestieren mit Masken unter der
Nase die ampelparteien wollen das
Infektionsschutzgesetz nochmals
verschärfen darin enthalten auch eine
Impfpflicht für das Personal in
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
die Impfung ist ein Eingriff in die
körperliche Unversehrtheit aber auch das
Recht auf körperliche Unversehrtheit der
schwachen und Hilfsbedürftigen ist ein
Grundrecht scharfer Widerspruch von der
AFD sie spricht von Zitat einer
unerhörten grundrechtseinschränkung der
FDP wirft sie Wortbruch vor
für den Griff nach der Macht haben sie
ihre Wähler verraten
um mitregieren zu dürfen sind Sie bereit
das Grundrecht auf körperliche
Unversehrtheit Artikel 2 Grundgesetz mit
den Füßen zu treten und nehmen Sie bitte
nie wieder das Wort Freiheit in den Mund
das ergänzte Gesetz würde künftig auch
erlauben Restaurants zu schließen oder
Messen und Kongresse zu verbieten der
Union in neuer Rolle als Opposition
langt das nicht den Ländern blieben zu
wenig Möglichkeiten die Pandemie zu
bekämpfen das folgt immer dem gleichen
Muster sie schließen Lücken und
versuchen Lücken zu schließen die sie
selber aufgerissen haben sie handeln zu
spät und sie handeln zu wenig seit an
seit gehen die ampelvertreter in den
Gegenangriff sie kontern dass die Union
im Sommer Maßnahmen wie 2G oder das
Boostern verpasst hätte von to little
und too late zu sprechen Angesicht einer
solchen Bilanz ist beschämt und
irreführend und bringt im Ende des Tages
nur Politik insgesamt in den diskredit 7
[Applaus]
mal wie das widrig Clubs und Bars
geschlossen werden dem designierten
Gesundheitsminister wirft die Union
konkret vor dass er angesichts der neuen
omicronvariante einen weiteren Lockdown
für denkbar halte doch das Gesetz
ermögliche eben keinen Lockdown Karl
Lauterbach wird ab wir dürfen die Bürger
nicht verunsichern dass wir Instrumente
abgegeben hätten für lange Zeit wenn wir
diese Instrumente benötigen dann werden
wir sie hier im Parlament sofort
einsetzen am Freitag soll das ergänzte
Infektionsschutzgesetz in
Sondersitzungen von Bundestag und
Bundesrat verabschiedet werden
und noch Bundesgesundheitsminister Jens
Spahn ist uns aus Berlin zugeschaltet
guten Abend Herr Spahn schönen guten
Abend Frau Slomka wie ist das wenn man
da im Bundestag sitzt und reihenweise
unions-
[Musik]
deren Auslaufen eingefordert hat
nun Frau slomköders die epidemische Lage
als Rechtsinstrument die haben wir ja im
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit quasi
mit entwickelt vor eineinhalb Jahren die
Idee war ja eben in der
Ausnahmesituation auch mit Verordnungen
viel regeln zu können und ja ich habe
diese rechtliche Debatte dass wir diese
rechtliche Ausnahmesituation verlassen
könnten zu einem falschen Zeitpunkt
geführt das habe ich ja auch schon
öffentlich gesagt es ging mir nie darum
dass wir die Maßnahmen beenden können
das habe ich genauso klar gesagt dass
wir weiter Maßnahmen brauchen ich habe
mich da korrigieren können in der
Einschätzung ich hätte mir gewünscht die
ampelparteien hätten das auch gekonnt
dann hätten wir jetzt nicht zum dritten
Mal in drei Wochen das
Infektionsschutzgesetz ändern müssen
eine andere Einschätzung die Sie
vielleicht korrigieren könnten oder
sollten es die dass es eine Impfpflicht
nicht erforderlich ist oder nicht
notwendig ist sie sind ja nach wie vor
dagegen
zuerst einmal finde ich die Debatte
wichtig denn die hat ja einen Grund wir
haben gut 12 Millionen ungeimpfte
Erwachsene in Deutschland und diese Zahl
ist zu groß das sehen wir ja denn es
sind vor allem ja auch die ungeimpften
wo wir die große Stärke Belastung auf
den Intensivstationen sehen die auch
maßgeblich dazu beitragen dass die
Infektionszahlen so hoch werden und
deswegen auch ja es ist mir schon
wichtig die Debatte muss geführt werden
ich bin auch sehr konsequent zum
Beispiel für 2G geimpft genesen das
hätten wir schon viel früher machen
sollen meinetwegen auch für das ganze
Jahr 2022 2G aber eine allgemeine
Impfpflicht so wichtig die Debatte ist
finde ich hat nicht nur rechtliche
Aspekte sie hat gesellschaftliche
Aspekte ethische medizinische und ganz
praktische wie wollen Sie das eigentlich
durchsetzen eine solche allgemeine
Impfpflicht und auch kontrollieren auf
der Straße dann etwa ob jemand geimpft
ist oder nicht ich habe heute mit meinem
österreichischen Kollegen in Brüssel ich
war ja heute beim gesundheitsministerrat
genau darüber gesprochen das Umsetzen
ist dann eben auch ein Teil dieser
Debatte das gilt natürlich für alle
Pflichten dass sie irgendwie umgesetzt
werden das auch nicht an jeder Ecke
einen Polizist steht der irgendwas
kontrolliert aber sie haben zum Beispiel
im Interview mit dem Spiel gesagt ja da
kann man sich schon vorstellen wie dann
die Linken Politikerinnen und
impfgegnerin Sarah Wagenknecht von der
Polizei abgeschleppt wird das ist doch
Quatsch also es geht doch nicht um einen
Impfzwang das wie so erzählen sie sowas
da würden dann Leute von der Polizei
abgeschleppt das stimmt doch gar nicht
nee es geht ja um die konkrete
Ausgestaltung und wenn sie es Bußgeld
bewähren 300 600.000 Euro und jemand
zahlt seinen Bußgeld nicht dann ist auch
beim Nichtzahlen von Bußgeld irgendwann
möglicherweise eine weitere strafstufe
angezeigt ja da ist das übrigens auch so
wenn sie beim Schwarzfahren ihr Ticket
oder ihren Strafzettel nicht zahlen dann
folgt irgendwann auch eine weitere
strafstufe ich habe heute mit meinem
österreichischen Kollegen auch darüber
gesprochen und wissen Sie was der
Unterschied ist die Österreicher haben
ein Register aller geimpften Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in Österreich und die
schreiben einfach automatisch nicht
geimpften an und stellen den sozusagen
ein entsprechenden Bescheid zu dass sie
zahlen müssen das ist eine andere Form
der Durchsetzung als die Kontrolle auf
der Straße so ich sag ja nur das muss
debattiert werden ich sehe das
grundsätzlich skeptisch aber ich finde
es genauso wichtig und ich verstehe das
auch gut dass eines im Gesichts der Lage
in der wir sind diese Debatte geführt
wird befinde ich bei so einer
grundsätzlichen Debatte darf man die
auch ruhig mal von allen Aspekten
beleuchten denn da geht es wirklich um
ein sehr grundsätzliches Verhältnis von
Staat und Bürgern von Freiheit des
Einzelnen und Verantwortung für die
Gesundheit des anderen nicht so
wahnsinnig viel Zeit für Debatten
während die Krankenhäuser in die Knie
gehen und und Menschen sterben und Ärzte
auf Impfstoff warten warum ist das jetzt
wieder so dass nicht genügend Impfstoff
da ist wo er gebraucht wird das fällt ja
in Ihrer Verantwortung als als
Bundesgesundheitsminister wir haben
Impfstoff sichergestellt für die
nächsten Wochen dass die impfziele
erreicht werden dass über 30 Millionen
Impfungen stattfinden können und das
nächste Woche zum Beispiel 8 Millionen
Dosen bei auch wieder verfügbar sind
deswegen freue ich mich und deswegen
freue ich mich wenn wir Ende diesen
Monat sagen können Ziel erreicht
ist das gut für Deutschland aber die
Ärzte ein bisschen anders die ja heute
bis mittags um 12 Uhr für die nächste
Woche den Impfstoff bestellen mussten
und die maximal 30 bayern-tech Dosen pro
niedergelassenem Arzt bekommen weil das
rationiert worden ist die Leute wollen
aber nur mal Bayern Tag haben wenn sie
damit gute Erfahrungen gemacht haben
also da an der Stelle läuft doch
wirklich schief
was ich aktuell sehe ist dass auch die
Zahl der Impfung mit moderner sehr stark
gestiegen ist dass auch die Akzeptanz
für diesen Impfstoff steigt das sind
zwei gleich gute Impfstoffe beide für
diese boosterimpfung zugelassen Mana
Impfstoffe und deswegen sehe ich
jedenfalls dass wir jeden Tag so viel
impfen wie schon lange nicht mehr in
dieser Impfkampagne ich weiß darum dass
das natürlich vor Ort in den Arztpraxen
auch in der Umstellung auch stärker auf
moderner jetzt auch zu manchem Frust
geführt hat das habe ich ja auch schon
adressiert entsprechend aber
entscheidend ist doch eines wenn wir
drauf schauen dass wir gerade so schnell
wie kein anderes Land in Europa und
wenige andere Länder auf der Welt dieser
boosterkampagne richtig Tempo geben ich
sage noch einmal ich verstehe das ist im
Alltag diesen Frust diese Wut gibt und
dafür kann ich mich nur entschuldigen
aber ich gleichzeitig wenn ich aufs
Gesamtbild schaue gerade auch in Brüssel
in der Diskussion heute sind wir in
Deutschland das Land mit den Europa das
am schnellsten grad die Booster am
Kampagne ausroll rausfährt und das ist
doch erstmal das entscheidende dass wir
mit dem Boostern in Unterschied machen
also angesichts der der Lernkurve die
sie dann ja auch im Amt hatten oder der
diversen Momente wo sie sagten da habe
ich vielleicht eine Fehleinschätzung
gehabt oder hätte ich etwas anders
machen müssen gibt es einen Rat den sie
für ihren Nachfolger haben nach diesen
zwei Jahren pandemieerfahrung
also wenn ich einen Ratschlag hätte dann
würde ich ihnen Karl Lauterbach
persönlich geben wir beiden kennen uns
jetzt seit über 15 Jahren und das ist ja
jetzt eine regierungsübergabe auch eine
ministeramtsübergabe wie wir sie noch
nie hatten in der Geschichte der
Republik ich wäre gerne Minister
geblieben ich habe das gerne gemacht
auch weil ich das als besondere
Verantwortung erlebe und empfinde gerade
in dieser Zeit der Pandemie auch bei
aller Härte und bei aller Kritik ich
hätte gern diese Aufgabe der Pandemie
auch gern zu Ende gebracht aber jetzt
steht eben der Wechsel an und den werden
wir ordentlich machen ich wünsche Karl
Lauterbach dabei alles Gute eine
glückliche Hand auch im Interesse
unseres Landes er hat meine
Unterstützung und meine Handynummer hat
er sowieso wenn etwas ist können wir
auch das dann besprechen
in seinem vermutlich erstmal vorerst
letzten heute schon Interview als
Bundesgesundheitsminister ich danke
Ihnen Herr Spahn sehr gerne
mit Corona geht es jetzt auch in den
Nachrichten erst noch mal weiter Gundula
in Deutschland mehren sich Hinweise auf
Unsicherheiten bei der Erfassung der
coronazahlen viele Fälle würden wohl
nicht registriert heißt es zum Beispiel
aus Sachsen wegen Überlastung der
Gesundheitsämter und Kliniken das
Robert-Koch-Institut meldete 36.000 und
59 Neuinfektionen binnen eines Tages
9.694 weniger als vor einer Woche
399 Todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
Tage Inzidenz sank recht deutlich auf
432,2
die künftige ampelregierung hat die
Besetzung weiterer Posten bekannt
gegeben neuer Beauftragte für die
ostdeutschen Bundesländer wird der
Thüringer SPD-Politiker Carsten
Schneider der 45-Jährige wird als
Staatsminister im Kanzleramt arbeiten
und nicht wie sein Vorgänger Marco
wanderwitz im Wirtschaftsministerium und
als neue
Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung wurde die
SPD-Politikerin Rehm alabali Radovan
ernannt die 31-Jährige arbeitete bislang
auf dem gleichen Posten in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
die Volksgruppe der ruinja verklagt den
Facebook Mutterkonzernen Meta wegen
Hetze auf mehr als 130 Milliarden Euro
Schadenersatz Facebooks Algorithmus habe
Desinformation und Gewalt Aufrufe
gefördert die zu echter Gewalt gegen die
ruinja geführt hätten so die Anklage bei
einer militär-kampagne 2017 in ihrem
Heimatland Myanmar wurden tausende
Angehörige der muslimischen Minderheit
ermordet so Hilfsorganisationen
hunderttausende flohen in das
benachbarte Bangladesch
80 Jahre nach dem japanischen Angriff
auf den US-Stützpunkt Pearl Harbor auf
Hawaii hat US-Präsident beiden der Opfer
gedacht gemeinsam mit seiner Frau ehrte
er an der Gedenkstätte zum Zweiten
Weltkrieg in Washington die
amerikanischen Patrioten die bei dem
Angriff der Japaner am 7 dezember 1941
ums Leben kamen bei dem Überfall auf
Pearl Harbor wurden mehr als
2.400 US-Soldaten und Zivilisten getötet
der japanische Angriff führte zum
Eintritt der USA in den Zweiten
Weltkrieg
vielleicht waren die beiden Herren sogar
ganz froh dass sie sich pandemiebedingt
nur per Videocall treffen konnten
manchmal ist räumliche Distanz ja auch
angenehm die russische Seite schaffte es
aber gleich für die notwendige
Bildsprache zu sorgen Präsident Putin im
Vordergrund und betont entspannt Joe
Biden nur klein auf dem Bildschirm warum
das Weiße Haus zunächst keine eigenen
Sequenzen veröffentlichte also quasi den
Gegenschuss bleibt das Geheimnis des
dortigen pressestabs so gab es von
diesem Ereignis der Weltpolitik über
viele Stunden nur die russische
Perspektive bis die USA mit eigenen
Bildern nachgezogen
Putin dürfte es eh als Erfolg betrachten
dass seine truppenmanöver an der Grenze
zur Ukraine für so viel Unruhe sorgen er
testet das westliche Bündnis so viel
scheint klar Christian sembericht
was ist Militärmanöver
truppenkonzentration oder
Kriegsvorbereitung Moskau hat dieses
verwirr Spiel perfektioniert und
Wladimir Putin hat damit einen
videogipfel mit dem US-Präsidenten
erzwungen hallo
gut dass wir uns wiedersehen sagt Joe
Biden hallo Herr Präsident antwortet
Putin der von den USA Garantien will wir
seit mehreren Tagen fordert dass die
NATO nicht gern Osten erweitert wird und
dass es in der Nähe keine Waffensysteme
gibt die die Russische Föderation
bedrohen
eine rote Linie nennt Moskau eine
nato-ost-erweiterung doch die USA wollen
Russland keine Garantien geben und
drohen vor dem Gipfel mit Sanktionen
was ich gerade tue ist ein sehr
umfassendes Paket an Maßnahmen
zusammenzustellen von dem ich glaube
dass es Herrn Putin sehr sehr schwer
machen wird das weiter zu betreiben
[Musik]
seit mehr als sieben Jahren tobt der
Krieg in der Ostukraine die Gebiete
werden von Pro russischen Separatisten
kontrolliert und Russland lässt auf
seinem Gebiet Truppen aufmarschieren der
ukrainische Präsident selenski warnte
gestern noch einmal vor Russland
ist ein Symbol für die ganze Ukraine für
die Streitkräfte die weiter ihre
wichtige Mission erfüllen die
Verteidigung der Freiheit und
Souveränität gegenüber dem russischen
Aggressor zwei Stunden haben Putin und
beiden heute miteinander gesprochen nach
Angaben des Weißen Hauses wiederholte
Joe Biden dabei seine Drohung sollte der
Konflikt militärisch eskalieren Mr
Russland mit starken wirtschaftlichen
Sanktionen rechnen
Nachfrage an unsere Amerika
Korrespondentin Claudia Bates was hört
man aus Washington wie konkret sind denn
diese Sorgen wegen eines möglichen
Angriffs Russlands auf die Ukraine
ja das wird hier von der US-Regierung
außerordentlich ernst genommen es gab ja
auch gerade noch mal US-Geheimdienst
Informationen die nach außen gedrungen
sind dass Putin einen mehr Fronten
Angriff plane mit bis zu 175
000 Soldaten das wird also sehr ernst
genommen und das ist das Szenario auf
dass die USA sich vorbereiten nun ist
auch klar was man nicht möchte nämlich
sich selber militärisch engagieren was
bleibt also deshalb ist die Rede von
sehr sehr schmerzhaften und den bisher
schlimmsten Sanktionen gegen Russland
die sich vor allem gegen den
Finanzsektor richten sollen zum Beispiel
sollen möglicherweise russische Banken
vom internationalen Zahlungsverkehr
ausgeschlossen werden militärisch gibt
es auch Möglichkeiten nämlich die
Ukraine noch stärker mit Waffen zu
unterstützen und Truppen zusätzliche
Truppen in die osteuropäischen
NATO-Länder zu schicken um diese
abzusichern insgesamt aber setzen die
USA auf ein diplomatischen Weg und der
Ausgangspunkt dafür soll das
minsker-abkommen sein im Leben vergeht
es darum jetzt im Moment Druck auszuüben
also auch abzuschrecken spielt da in den
USA auch Nord Stream 2 noch mal eine
Rolle das ist ja für unsere neue
Berliner Koalition hier einen ein
heikles Thema
ja also Nord Stream 2 wird ganz klar als
verhandlungsspielmasse angesehen Joe
Biden steht hier innenpolitisch unter
starkem Druck deswegen wegen der
Zugeständnisse die er Deutschland
gemacht hat als er zunächst mal
natürlich mit Deutschland ein gutes
Verhältnis pflegen wollte aber er steht
unter Druck von zwei Seiten nämlich von
den Demokraten und den Republikanern die
wegen Nord Stream 2 hier sogar den
Verteidigungshaushalt blockieren im
Moment nun haben die USA gerade noch mal
betont dass sie das gute Verhältnis mit
Deutschland natürlich aufrechterhalten
wollen auch mit der neuen deutschen
Regierung aber man es gibt auch vage
Informationen darüber dass es bereits
ein Verständigung mit Deutschland
darüber gebe dass wenn Putin die Ukraine
angreifen würde dass dann Sanktionen
gegen Nord Stream 2 gegen Beteiligte
verhängt werden beziehungsweise es einen
Stock geben wird
danke schön Claudia für diese
Einschätzungen aus Washington
nicht nur die Beziehungen zu Russland
sind denkbar schlecht geworden mit China
gibt es ja noch eine zweite Großmacht
mit Expansionsdrang die Washington in
Schach halten will und mit dem
amerikanisch chinesischen Verhältnis
geht es jetzt bei Kunde der weiter nach
der Ankündigung der US-Regierung wegen
Menschenrechtsverletzungen in China
keine diplomatischen Vertreter zu den
Olympischen Winterspielen nach Peking zu
entsenden hat die chinesische Regierung
mit so wirklich resoluten Gegenmaßnahmen
gedroht der Boykott sei eine
Verschwörung zur Störung der Olympischen
Spiele so ein Sprecher des
Außenministeriums in Peking der
chinesische Vertreter bei den Vereinten
Nationen nannte die Entscheidung eine
politische Farce die an die Mentalität
des Kalten Krieges erinnern
die Finanzmärkte legten heute zu und
reagierten klar auch auf erste
Äußerungen zu der neuen virus-variante
die die Hoffnung nähren
ormicon sei möglicherweise nicht
gefährlicher als die bisher bekannten
Varianten des Erregers Stefanie berrett
der Optimismus überwiegt also Daten zur
schlechteren Konjunkturerwartung ja da
sind sich die Finanzmärkte überraschend
sicher sie schütteln derzeit jegliche
Angst vor der neuen corona-variante ab
so griffen Anleger heute auch wieder
beherzt zu der deutsche Aktienindex
schoss fast drei Prozent oder 433 Punkte
in die Höhe gewisse Winter wird jüngsten
Konjunkturprognosen zufolge noch
ungemütlich vor allem für Handel
Dienstleistungen und Industrie Hoffnung
schöpfte man aber heute aus den neuen
Produktionszahlen im Oktober stellten
deutsche Unternehmen gut 3% mehr Güter
her als noch im September an solchen
erholungstagen zählen Automobilwerte wie
VW und Daimler ja traditionell immer zu
den Gewinneraktien den herausragenden
Kurssprung machte heute allerdings
Volkswagen mit
+8%. dahinter stecken Spekulationen
wonach VW einen Börsengang seiner
sportwagentochter Porsche vorbereitet
mit den Einnahmen könnte Volkswagen
seine Transformation hin zur
Elektromobilität mit finanzieren und ein
größeres Aktienpaket von Porsche würden
wohl dabei die Familien piesch und
Porsche erwerben diese Informationen
gehen auf Berichte des Handelsblatts
zurück stammen aus dem Konzernumfeld
sind also durchaus ernst zu nehmen wie
es hier auf dem Parkett hieß und wir
werden berichten vielen Dank Stefanie
nach Frankfurt
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball Champions
League in der Gruppenphase hat RB
Leipzig Manchester City 2:1 besiegt ein
Erfolg für leipzigs-trainer Achim Beyer
lorzer der nach der Trennung von Jessy
March das Team leitet Leipzig ist damit
Gruppen dritte und spielt nun weiter in
der Europa League schon vor zwei Monaten
wurden die Nobelpreisträger bekannt
gegeben heute wurden die Ehrungen
durchgeführt wegen Corona nicht wie
üblichen Stockholm sondern in den
Heimatländern der Preisträger so erhielt
der Hamburger Klimaforscher Klaus
Hasselmann in Berlin den
Physik-Nobelpreis für seine Modelle zum
Erdklima ebenfalls im Haus der dortigen
Max-Planck-Gesellschaft wurde der
Chemiker Benjamin list für seine
Forschung zur asymmetrischen organo
Katalyse ausgezeichnet ein wichtiges
Werkzeug in der Arzneimittelforschung
und verwüstlich ist ja so ein schönes
altmodisches Wort und auf ihn passt es
ganz wunderbar Rock Ikone Neil Young
mittlerweile 76 Jahre alt veröffentlicht
in dieser Woche sein neues Album
zusammen mit seiner legendären Band
Crazy Horse hat er sich dafür aufs Land
zurückgezogen in eine zum Tonstudio
umgebaute Scheune die dem Album dann
auch gleich den Titel gab the bar und
die ländliche Natur drumherum war nicht
nur Inspiration sondern auch Thema Neil
Young sieht sich nicht nur als Musiker
sondern auch als Aktivist darüber hat
Ralf Rettich mit ihm gesprochen über
Musik und Politik
eine einsame Scheune mitten in den Rocky
Mountains sieht alles recht friedlich
aus aber das täuscht
[Musik]
drinnen macht Neil Young in seinem Zorn
Luft wer rettet Mutter Erde wenn ihre
Kinder schutzzufrieden
Neil Young und seine Band Crazy Horse
sind alle über 70 Jahre alt nicht bloß
die Jungen sind wütend über die
Untätigkeit beim Klimawandel
das Gleichgewicht in der Natur ist so
wichtig und wir zerstören das die Natur
wird es weiterhin geben das ist nicht
das Problem wir sind es wir die es so
nicht weitergeben wird
ich habe Sorge dass wir es wirklich übel
vergeigen weil wir als Planet nicht
zusammenarbeiten
seine erste Farm kaufte Neil Young vor
50 Jahren er hatte in Woodstock gespielt
war erfolgreich jetzt zog es ihn aufs
Land
[Musik]
es ist als ob das Land die Songs
schreibe und nicht er so sieht es nilian
allerdings liegt im Land für ihn gerade
vieles im Argen erst kürzlich wurde der
Kanadier deshalb US-Staatsbürger um
mitbestimmen zu können
ich bin so much Division in den USA war
so viel von Spaltung die Rede in den
ganzen letzten Jahren unter Trump denkst
du
wer ich erinnere mich nicht an den Mann
kenne ich nicht
nein ich denke es läuft erst noch
aufgrund es geht noch weiter runter
bevor es aufwärts geht ich bin nicht
sicher aber es besteht eine echte Chance
dass dann das wahre Amerika
wiederzusehen ist mit Werten wie dass
die Leute sich respektieren sich helfen
auf Leute achten die nicht so viel haben
wie Sie selbst
[Musik]
don't forget Love ist der letzte Song
des Albums
vergiss die Liebe nicht
[Musik]
mit der Anstalt geht es gleich weiter
und um 0 Uhr meldet sich Christina von
ungarn-sternberg mit unserem heute
journal Update heute journal gibt es
natürlich morgen wieder bis dahin auf
Wiedersehen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend aus diesem kleinen
unscheinbaren wolkenklecks über dem
Atlantik hat sich innerhalb von nur 24
Stunden ein veritables Orkantief
entwickelt der Kerndruck ist um mehr als
50 Hektopascal gesunken das Ergebnis
waren hohe Wellen und
Windgeschwindigkeiten im Mittel von mehr
als 130 Kilometer pro Stunde also volle
Orkanstärke heute Nachmittag lag der
Kerndruck bei 957 Hektopascal und dieses
Orkantief Harry beschäftigt uns auch in
Mitteleuropa seine wolkenschleppe zieht
nämlich ostwärts und dabei entwickelt
sich hier über den Westalpen ein neues
kleines Tief das uns morgen auch Schnee
in Süddeutschland bringen wird heute
Nacht geht es aber erst mal mit Regen
los und wenn der hier zu uns zieht wird
immer mehr Schnee daraus und bis morgen
früh erreichen diese Schnee und
Regenfälle nordfries und Franken glatt
kann es heute Nacht aber wieder fast
überall sein bei Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen +4 und -8 Grad und morgen wird
es dann gefährlich aus der Schweiz
heraus in Baden-Württemberg und Bayern
bis nach Thüringen gibt es kräftige
Schnee Schneeregen und gefährlichen
gefrierenden eisregenfälle wir haben es
allerdings auch mal mit Sonnenschein zu
tun ganz im Osten hier zum Beispiel in
Sachsen oder auch in Brandenburg genauso
wie in Ostfriesland und am Niederrhein
die Temperaturen dazu liegen Morgen
meist bei -1 + 3 Grad im Westen ist es
milder und winterlich geht es in den
nächsten Tagen auch weiter guten Abend